it was just a weird we we always have
weird weeks every week is weird uh but
the lies of the administration and the
conflicting
uh information from the administration
and how nobody seems coordinated and
biden's fallen off a bike and that's
like his best moment of the week uh here
is uh press secretary uh karine
jean-pierre let's i always have to note
she is a black lesbian it's very
important to tell everybody that uh
contradicting
energy secretary uh secretary granholm
about what's going on with this gas tax
what do you say to lawmakers who are
already calling this federal gas tax
holiday a gimmick and saying best case
scenario it'll save drivers about 20
bucks a month well it there's no doubt
this is a modest if it were just the
federal gas tax right 18 cents is
you know is a modest uh you know a
modest amount uh we're talking about uh
you know 18 cents uh per gallon which is
going to go a long way if you look at
the average of states that's 30 cents
just looking at those two things that's
almost 50 cents
that's going to go a long way for three
months
okay so first off they're contradicting
each other that's fine we expect that
but also this silliness about 18 cents
and 30 cents and even if you fill up
your car every day i mean we're talking
about maybe you know 30 50 bucks a month
i'm not saying it's nothing but in light
of inflation and everything else uh this
this all just shows you these people
seemingly have no idea what's going on
reboy you don't like these people do you
i mean that goes without saying no i
mean it's it's
look i mean it's ridiculous
the idea that
inflation here is caused by anything but
the fact that they pre they put more
money into circulation
than uh than most other economies
um you know in the world combined in the
last two years um you know the the fact
the idea that that's got nothing to do
with it is so fanciful and absurd
that um
you know i mean look i mean i hate to
quote vladimir putin but in order to
believe it you have to be
illiterate
but
they're going to try it and um
i don't know i don't know if anyone buys
it i mean i i am uh i'm pessimistic
about the the intelligence of the
average person
so you never know
now pessimistic account
like the
the the the administration i think this
whole gas tax holiday is a trap
so the idea is that you you repeal it
and that gives a biden an opening to
attack you know every gas station in the
country and say see you need to lower
your price but the inflationary pressure
is already there the the tax itself does
not it's not a retail tax it's a
wholesale tax it's paid very early in
the structure of production
i'll make a prediction right here that i
don't think it's going to make any
difference even if it passes
but it'll allow the administration to
claim that the energy companies and the
oil companies the gas company retailers
have somehow pocketed
uh the the tax cut and that will provide
an opening for them to do all sorts of
you know attacks and accusing
the sellers of of gouging so i think the
whole thing is just a big trap and it
does illustrate just how the level of
economic ignorance from this um or just
sheer lies from this administration is
shocking they don't understand price
formation the the price you pay at the
pump there's not a perfect reflection of
the costs along the production structure
prices final prices especially are
always
retrospective of previous costs
and supplies and then also speculative
of of future uh supplies and and demand
and so you have an administration
demanding lower gas prices at the same
time the waging an unrelenting
rhetorical and regulatory war on fossil
fuels
and and anything other than as janet
yellen says the wind and the sun those
are good kinds of energy right which
constitutes about 14 of american energy
consumption and the rest is evil and and
and they want to get rid of it and you
cannot inspire uh more production and
lower prices under these under these
conditions it's a war on on energy and
enterprise and it's it's outrageous and
it's hardly a surprise it's going to
lead to you know more
pressure from two directions one
monetary as david says uh but but also
the supply constraints and and refining
capacity is you know very intense right
now
and by the way they're fully admitting
that they are waging that war they're
not even hiding that they are waging
that war they're telling us they're
waging that war